the best advice i can give somebody is
do something that you think is
interesting
and let the waves catch you we felt a
little bad
i i certainly i did about leaving the
university
when uh i thought very interesting work
on artificial intelligence
was really on the verge of taking place
so
18 people we gathered 50
000 us dollars we studied alibaba in my
apartment
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
seven
lessons from elon musk jeff bezos and
other billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one don't chase the wave with
jeff bezos
the best advice i can give somebody is
do something that you think is
interesting
and let the waves catch you you know
something that i see people do which i
don't think is a is a good idea
is they try to chase the current thing i
saw this so much in
1997 and 1998 1999
with respect to the internet there were
you know in 94 and 95
96 97 mostly
the people who were you know the kind of
the earlier you get the more true this
is but
you know the people who were sort of
looking at this space and starting
companies were genuinely interested in
it they thought it was really cool
um by the time you got to 1999
like doctors were stopping you know
screw that doctor thing
i'm going start a dot-com company you
know and so
um that really made no sense whatsoever
you know people were sort of abandoning
the things they were genuinely
interested in trying to catch a wave and
whenever you try to catch a wave you're
almost always too late
so it's it's better to just i mean if
you're paddling after it you basically
have to wait in place and let it come to
you
lesson number two manage your time well
with elon musk
you're running you're ceo of two
companies you're chairman of solar city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep uh yeah
sometimes not enough sleep is really
great because
because if i find if i don't get enough
sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
are that way
and and also um like i try to sort of
figure out what's the
right amount of sleep because like i
found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it
that would get less done because um
my mental acuity would be affected um
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours
on average per night um that's not too
bad
yeah right and any other tips on average
though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously
i mean do you do you find i mean i know
you're up here monday tuesday is it
all tesla when you're up in silicon
valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a service
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email during
um interstitial periods like you're in a
car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake um
and uh and so that's really helpful to
have
email for spacex and tesla integrated
on my phone um and then
uh and and then it's just you have to
apply a lot of hours to actual working
actually working so
the way i generally do it is i'll be
working at spacex on monday and then
monday night flight to the bay area
spent tuesday and wednesday at the bay
area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night it's been thursday and
friday
at spacex in in
the last several months then i would fly
back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
or spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex
lesson number three pursue your dream
with bill gates
we felt a little bad i i certainly i did
about leaving the university
when uh i thought very interesting work
on artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now
you know it's taken a long time the rate
of progress which is hard to make
numeric
in both those areas has been quite
modest i mean we haven't gone backwards
or anything but
ai has turned out to be a tougher
problem which is
is fascinating and now there there are
some interesting advances and likewise
symbolic
type things there are some now advances
so we thought we'd miss
uh being more at the center of those now
through at least funding microsoft
research
we get to have some level of involvement
in that
one of paul's ideas was to build a 360
emulator that was the dominant mainframe
of the time use bit slice
architecture to just you know blow away
the pricing on
mainframe computing but we decided that
was kind of boring uh
compared to personal computing a company
came along about five years later two pi
and did it uh they didn't do the
software piece right that's why they
failed uh
because we still think it was a good
idea but we didn't have anything even
close to hey let's build a computer that
we want to use
that we want to have as a tool for our
own uh
messing around and communication and
creativity that
that kind of got at the center of our
thinking even from
the early days lesson number four ignore
your haters with grant cardone
nobody's got more haters than that but
it stops a lot of people and it doesn't
stop you
yeah because because because i i you
know it's a different
for me like
i understand that
if you get if you're going to get
success you're going to get the haters
that's the price
or one of the costs that's one of the
prices okay so because
it goes back to what i said earlier all
haters
first of all we should not admire haters
the way we do
we even call them haters they're not
haters they're quitters
they're quitters all haters are quitters
like this should be this should be the
title of your your thing is a quiz
all haters all haters yeah including me
anytime i hate on something okay i am
i quit on that thing like i hate drugs i
quit drugs
i hate drugs i hate people that use
drugs i don't trust people that use
drugs
like no drug is safe for me and and i
know i believe
that no drug is safe for other people
now some people can be like no no
i'm using cannabis recreational it's
cool man and i use
psychedelics and i do this good dude i
hate drugs i want to make it clear i
hate drugs and i i hate drugs for you
and i hate trucks for him i hate drugs
for everybody so i can be wrong
but right now i'm gonna hate drugs why
because i quit drugs
now if you're hating on grant cardone
and i hadn't done anything to you
i'm over here minding my own business or
building my own business
you know minding micromanaging my own
business so it grows
so so if i'm doing that okay and you're
hating on me why you hating on me
now he uses social media too much these
are every example i go over it's because
you don't use it enough
he works too much because you don't use
you you don't work enough
he doesn't spend enough time with his
kids you don't even have kids
like i got people hating on me because i
got my kids on my plane oh you're gonna
ruin your kids
if i'm gonna ruin my kids i'm gonna ruin
them private
you know so so um what are you quitting
on like
so i it's very very important for me
like when i hate on somebody i need to
understand
did i quit on something or am i
legitimately hating on this person for a
reason because i'm trying to make a
i'm trying to make a statement publicly
and there are
there are people i publicly hate on and
why do you do that
because i want to make it clear that
they should not be doing business with
this person they should not be admiring
this person they should not
like as an opinion leader i think i have
some responsibility to tell people you
don't want to follow that if you're
going to follow him don't follow me
yeah you can't follow both of us
and think that you're going to get any
place which is a huge problem today with
social media
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five learn
to say no with oprah winfrey you um
are now the ceo of your company you're
the owner
and the ceo and you've got thousands of
people working for you yeah
and as a ceo do you have to say no to
people all the time and is that hard to
do
uh you get other people who say no that
no okay um
saying no is hard that is one of the big
big
lessons life lessons for me i i i grew
up obviously
girl uh raised in the south women need
to please wanting to please everybody
so it took me a long time to get that
lesson of only saying yes to what you
intend to say yes to and and so
i tried to do all of my business
decisions and personal decisions
based upon my intention lesson number
six
build trust with jack ma trust is the
most important thing as we discussed
this a few minutes ago
if people give me when i had no money
because when alibaba started
18 founders in my apartment i told
everybody say
put you all your money savings on the
table
leaving the money
for for 10 months food and
room you know rent what's that
the money you have put on the table i
want to gather the money and nobody
should borrow the money from parents
nobody should borrow money from friends
because i don't want to make your
parents and friends bankruptcy because
doing alibaba
so 18 people we gathered
50 000 u.s dollars we studied alibaba in
my apartment
and those people actually
none of us have money but if if somebody
say i give you 1 million u.s dollars
and i give you trust which one i would
choose
i choose those people who give me the
trust
because it's the trust that make make
us be united it's the trust
i think 18 founders they trust me
because they trust me i have to be very
loyalty
to them and loyal to the mission that uh
that we have i think a lot of
entrepreneurship know that
i hate people work for me i want people
work for the mission that we agreed
together
because you don't want people work for
me because people like me
when i look when i look further this
guy's a handsome wayne get closer he's
so ugly
everybody in the world the same you
should not get closer
further is good so you think a jack is
great but you know if you get closer
not necessarily i i'll be angry i will
happy i'm happy
i got but when people trusting you
that's the most valuable things i think
later when we got a lot of events
venture capitalists invested us the
thing they noticed is that because
my team trust me and i trust
my teams and lesson number seven the
last one before very special bonus clip
is model natural leaders with warren
buffett
if you look around the world at the
people that
succeed and the people that other people
want to work with the natural leaders
it isn't because they have the highest
high cure they can kick a football the
furthest or anything like that
they're people that you want to work
with i mean i've got a wonderful friend
named tom murphy i know
i would do anything for him you know
he's never going to ask me to do it but
i mean i want it
but i want to do it i i want to do it i
mean he's done so many things for me and
then
and you know i you know you don't have
to pay me to do it or anything of the
sort that
that that's what you want to you want to
look for that and then you want to be
that
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated inspired
you have a 35 chance of following
through but when you get motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you you've
got
440 000 customers 145 countries
um where do you go from here well
uh we want to make sure we beat amazon
and cloud database
so funny to hear you say that i mean
that's right very simple it's very
simple uh
it's just like playing basketball
if you you know if you're playing
basketball you want to beat the warriors
you want to be you know
uh you want to win the championship uh
so our job we have the best database in
the world
uh we've got deliver it in the context
of
a a cloud that's as easy to use as
amazon
but secure and that's the key thing
amazon has great ease of use we've got
to marry that to security and all the
capabilities to the autonomous database
and will be great
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there first thing i say is
thank you that's my first thing even
before i'm awake even before my eyes are
really fully open
i i say thank you i can feel the
gratitude like
i'm still here